Guten Morgen, Thomas.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du gegen René Benko wurde ein Haftbefehl in Italien erlassen.
Endlich eine zeitnahe Lösung für das Milliardärsproblem.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 508 vom 5. Dezember 2024.
Was ist Nikolausi?
Krampus. Ja, jetzt werden die Geschenke aus dem Hut gezogen.
Oder verwichtelt. Oder so.
Ist ja eh gerade ein großes Verwichteln angesagt von Macht. Machtverwichtelung.
So, da gibt's in den USA. Jemand, der steckt auch ein bisschen eklige Sachen
in die kleinen Tütchen rein zum Austauschen und ja, in Deutschland wissen wir
noch nicht so ganz genau, was wir kriegen. Ihr seid da ja schon weiter.
Österreich ist immer weiter im Abstieg in den Faschismus.
Eigentlich nicht so, aber sonst heißt es doch immer, ihr macht uns alles nach.
Na, das glaubt ihr nur.
Ihr seid sozusagen sowohl in der Vergangenheit als auch in der Zukunft gleichzeitig.
Du hast Österreich gut zusammengefasst.
Wenn man das dann zusammenrechnet, seid ihr eigentlich voll in der Gegenwart. Also ist doch okay.
So fühlt es sich fast nie an, aber ja, um den Eingangsgag aufzuklären.
Schöne Geschenke haben wir auch bekommen von der italienischen Justiz,
die nämlich, glaube ich, gestern war es, einen Haftbefehl gegen René Benko,
dem, glaube ich, in Deutschland auch bekannten Milliardär, Der ja auch, was hat er gekauft?
Kaufhaus des Westens, Galerie, Kaufhofs.
Genau, die Kaufhofkette und er war aber auch mit seiner Investitionsbude bei
so ein paar prominenteren Bauprojekten.
Unter anderem diesen großen Tower, der da in Hamburg in der HafenCity entstehen sollte.
So das Superteil und irgendwie das Tor zur Welt, bla bla bla,
was man immer so erzählt, wenn man große Häuser bauen will.
Und jetzt steht da halt so eine Betonruine rum und keiner weiß so richtig,
was sie jetzt damit machen sollen.
Ja, solche Beton-Ruinen gibt es gerade an vielen Stellen.
Ihm gehört ja auch das Chrysler-Building. Auch in Wien gibt es jetzt einige
sehr prominente, nicht fertiggestellte Neubauten.
Und da hat er für viel Ungemach gesorgt und auch mit den Konkursen,
dass viele Leute ihren Job verlieren.
Trotzdem lebt er immer noch in Saus und Braus.
Er ist letztens bei einer Jagd fotografiert worden mit einem sozialdemokratischen
Politiker, der dann daraufhin gleich sein Amt verloren hat.
Und die italienische Justiz hat jetzt einen internationalen Haftbefehl wegen
Mafia Straftatbeständen gegen ihn erlassen.
Und ich finde das gut, weil irgendwie ist jeder Milliardär ja ein Policy-Versagen
und wenn man eigentlich frühzeitig schon mit Mafia-Ermittlungen dagegen vorgeht,
verhindert man vielleicht, dass diese Leute in die Politik gehen, das wäre doch was.
Ist Mafia nicht, also ich weiß es gerade gar nicht, ist Mafia eigentlich schon
ein allgemeiner Begriff oder war das nicht mal auch irgendwann mal die konkrete
Bezeichnung für eine bestimmte Gruppe?
Ich glaube schon, dass es sich herleitet von Cosa Nostra und den bekannten Gruppen,
aber das italienische Recht hat sehr viel nachgerüstet, um diesen Gruppen Herr zu werden.
Und die haben ja relativ starke Bestimmungen, auch was die Unabhängigkeit der Justiz betrifft.
Und das zu Recht, das sind ja auch genügend RichterInnen und StaatsanwältInnen
in die Luft gejagt worden, als sie gegen solche Banden vorgegangen sind.
Und dass jetzt genau solche Bestimmungen verwendet werden gegen nicht nur René
Benko, sondern auch andere Leute in seinem Umfeld und das sind teilweise auch Menschen,
die ganz zentrale Rollen in der sogenannten Laura Privatstiftung haben.
Also was machst du als Milliardär, bevor du in den Konkurs gehst?
Du parkst all deine Milliarden in einer Privatstiftung und versuchst dadurch
sozusagen deinen Reichtum über den Konkurs zu retten.
Und auch von dieser Stiftung sind jetzt zentrale Personen hier mit diesem Haftbefehl
gesucht oder zumindest auch als Beschuldigte geführt.
Also ja, es ist wie immer bei Österreich. Poppern und bleibt spannend.
Ich habe mal kurz hier die Wortherkunft nachgeschlagen, weil mich das jetzt
gerade interessiert hat.
Und gut, da heißt es zunächst einmal, der Ursprung des Wortes Mafia ist unsicher,
halten wir das schon mal fest.
Mafioso gilt als das ältere Wort. Wahrscheinlich entstand Mafia in der sizilianischen
Sprache aus dem älteren Adjektiv Mafiusu.
Dieses war im 19. Jahrhundert in Sizilien gebräuchlich und hatte auf Männer
bezogen die Bedeutung angeberisch, arrogant, stolz, aber auch furchtlos und wagebutig.
Also ein Mafiusu war ein Angeber oder ein stolzer oder mutiger Mann.
Okay, also ich meine, Angeber passen natürlich dann, glaube ich,
ganz gut auf so Vögel wie René Benko und man fragt sich halt auch immer wieder, was eigentlich,
gibt es da nicht was von Ratio-Farm, also mit diesem Geld, das ist ja dann auch
immer für die Leute dann auch schnell ein Problem.
Also es gibt ja wenig reiche Leute, die wirklich an sich halten können. Ein paar gibt es.
Komischerweise ist das ja in Deutschland sehr verbreitet. Also die reichsten
Leute in Deutschland kennen kein Schwein.
Die geben keine Interviews, von denen gibt es kaum Fotos. Ja,
also diese Angeberei mit Geld ist in Deutschland nicht ganz so ein Problem.
Also es gibt natürlich solche, aber das ist jetzt so kulturhistorisch,
glaube ich, kann man sagen, so die Aldi-Brüder und der Lidl-Besitzer,
der Schwarz und so, die kennt keiner.
Also schon mit dem Namen nicht und dann gibt es auch kaum Interviews und Fotos schon gar nicht.
Also insofern sehr unmafiös. Allerdings in Österreich wird es dann schon ein
bisschen italienischer, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Ja, ja, wir sind doch näher, klar. Also da gibt es, ja stimmt eigentlich,
das wäre auch ein interessantes anthropologisches Fachgebiet,
mal irgendwie so die Psychologie von zu viel Geld zu erforschen.
Ja.
Das heißt ja immer, es verdirbt den Charakter. Mein Dataset ist sehr gering,
aber das, was ich habe an Daten, bestätigt dieses Sprichwort.
Deswegen sind wir so tolle Typen, weil wir nicht so mega reich sind.
Naja, okay, also Herr Benko, gut, mal schauen, was bei rauskommt.
Mir würden noch ein paar andere Leute da einfallen, die da sicherlich auch noch dazugehören.
Kommen wir zum Feedback und wie sollte es anders sein?
Das Zentrum des Feedbacks rotiert sich natürlich um das Wort zeitnah.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du Gelegenheit, die letzte Sendung nachzuhören? Ja.
Ich habe das Wort ja mal eingeworfen und habe so diese Vermutung in den Raum
gestellt, dass es sich dabei um ein Wort handelt, was irgendwie erst so in den
letzten 30 Jahren in Mode gekommen ist.
Das habe ich rein aus dem Bauch heraus gesagt und es gab dazu einige Anmerkungen.
Die erste, die sie konkret auf meine Prognose bezog, kam von Luise.
Die sagt, zur Frage, ob Wörter mehr oder weniger verwendet werden,
empfehle ich das digitale Wörterbuch zur deutschen Sprache.
Dort gibt es dann auch immer eine Wortverlaufskurve.
Spoiler, Tim hat recht, aber Zeitner ist schon wieder auf dem absteigenden Ast.
Und das ist wirklich interessant. Ich kannte das nicht. Also DWDS,
der deutsche Wortschatz von 1600 bis heute.
Also das nenne ich mal einen Ansatz.
Keine Ahnung, welche Quellen sie da alles ausgewertet haben,
aber wahrscheinlich Bücher und so weiter.
Und tatsächlich ist es so, dass zeitnah als Wort zwar irgendwie auch schon 1946
irgendwann mal von irgendjemandem verwendet wurde,
aber es dann eher so ein, naja, so ein Dasein fristete,
bis es dann so kurz vor 2000 nach oben schoss und dann also wirklich richtig populär wurde.
Was ist denn hier überhaupt die Einheit?
Frequenz pro eine Million Tokens. Aha, okay, gut, das kann ich jetzt nicht relaten.
Auf jeden Fall würde ich mal sagen, von 2000 bis heute mal so locker eine Verzehnfachung
mit seinem Peak 2021, was dann irgendwie in den letzten zwei Jahren wieder runterging
und es dieses Jahr wieder ein bisschen nach oben schlägt.
Mal gucken, wohin die Reise geht für zeitnah.
Aber das bestätigt zumindest schon mal meine Wahrnehmung. Vielen Dank.
Maddy Waters fügt dem noch hinzu, der Begriff zeitnah fiel früher eher in den
Bereich einer behördenunternehmensinternen Sondersprache.
Wahrscheinlich kam er Tim neu vor, weil er in den letzten Jahren vermehrt in
die öffentliche Polit- und Unternehmenskommunikation und damit in die Alltagssprache
ausbricht und dort im starken Kontrast zu gebräuchlicheren Synonymen wie schnell
oder kurzfristig steht.
Okay. Charlotte merkt an, ich erinnere mich dunkel, dass die drei im Neusprechfunk
mal über die Vokabel zeitnah gesprochen haben.
Und tatsächlich gab es dort auch einen Lexikon-Eintrag aus dem Jahr 2011.
Wenn ich nochmal kurz auf die Kurve schaue, also 2011 war die Popularität von
Zeitnah schon ausreichend dokumentiert.
Das Neusprechblog schreibt, beliebte Bläh-Vokabel, Klammern Pleonasmus,
klingt so schön eilig, bedeutet jedoch eigentlich irgendwann,
vielleicht aber auch nie und ist somit eine Antiphrase.
Umgangssprachliche Entsprechung ist der Satz, ja, ja, gleich. Und jetzt hau ab.
Das sollte man dann auch schleunigst tun, wird man doch von solchen Zeitgenossen
nie eine konkrete Antwort bekommen.
Also zeitnah, das passt natürlich dann wiederum zu dem Zusammenhang mit Unternehmen und Behörden.
Das heißt, es ist dann sozusagen eigentlich nur so eine halbe Versprechung.
Oder eine falsche Versprechung.
Geht aber noch weiter. Weiterer Kommentar von User Unknown bietet noch gleich
ein paar sprachliche Alternativen.
Neben schnell und kurzfristig empfehle ich flugsrasch, zügig,
unmittelbar, stante Pede, instantan, eilig, im Nu und augenblicklich.
Sicher findet man auch mit einem Synonymwörterbuch weitere Alternativen.
Mit zeitnah markiert man sich selbst als Bürokrat oder Journalist.
Okay, gut. Vielleicht auch als Podcaster, keine Ahnung. Namari3 fügt an ich
bin beruflich im Gutachterdeutsch unterwegs,
Worte wie zeitnah oder unverzüglich sind unabdingbar, um sich nicht festnageln
zu lassen das unterstützt diese Wahrnehmung und Holgi merkt an ich benutze zeitnah,
seitdem ich tagsüber als Business Casper Cosplay ich mach ja das Wort eigentlich
ich weiß nicht so richtig genau warum.
Dann von Dirion, bezüglich des Wortes zeitnah habe ich mich an die Leute gewandt,
die am besten den Zeitgeist verstehen und gleichsam wiedergeben können,
den Mitgliedern des Deutschen Bundestags.
Die Zeit hat ein nettes Tool, leider hinter der Paywall, mit dem man nach Wörtern
und Reden des Bundestags suchen kann.
Openparlament.tv bietet etwas ähnliches an, leider nicht für den gesamten Zeitraum
seit 1949. Die in der Folge aufgestellte These, es handelt sich bei Zeit nah
um ein eher neueres Wort im Sprachgebrauch, wird nach Auswertung der Bundestagsreden gestützt.
Bis 1990 taucht es nur vereinzelt auf, dann steigt die Anzahl der Nennungen
stetig und leicht schwankend bis zum globalen Maximum 2022, wie auch schon bei DWDS festgestellt.
Seitdem gilt das, was auch für die Politik des Bundestags gilt, es ging bergab.
2023 nur noch weniger Nennungen und so weiter und was 2024 ist,
das muss noch ausgekaspert werden. Ja,
vorloren fasst es zusammen mit zeitnah deutsches ASAP.
As soon as possible.
Deutsche ASAP, würde ich sagen. Was gleich so als Unternehmensform macht.
Wir haben wirklich ein wunderbar reflektiertes Publikum.
Das ist toll, oder? Also wirklich großartig. Das finde ich gut.
Das war ja nur so ein kleines Bauchgefühl, aber was?
Jetzt wissen wir alle mehr.
Ist ja auch wunderbar. Ich meine, Podcasts sind ja auch super, super,
Betankungsmaterial für so Partys. Also was man so in der Küche immer bespricht mit allen Leuten.
Hier kommt wirklich das das echte Partywissen anstarrt.
Nun denn, aber jetzt müssen wir uns mal den ernsten Themen zuwenden. Gibt ja ein paar.
Und da du ja heute dabei bist, müssen wir natürlich auch mal ein bisschen nach
Österreich gucken, auch wenn es gerade eigentlich überall so ein bisschen auseinander bricht.
Wir haben ganz viele neue Regierungen, manche, ja, also die meisten können ja
ein bisschen problematisch werden.
Schauen wir mal, was so kommt. Wie reflektierst du denn das?
Ja, wie du sagst, es gab Wahlen in Österreich schon im Herbst diesen Jahres
und im Moment wird gerade die neue Koalition verhandelt.
Wir sind die Wahlen ausgegangen, die FPÖ, also die österreichische AfD,
wurde stimmenstärkster Partei und gleichzeitig fand sich niemand,
der mit Herbert Kickl, dem Chef der FPÖ,
koalieren will.
In Deutschland gibt es ja so diese schöne Begrifflichkeit gesichert rechtsextrem.
Bei uns gibt es keine staatliche Stelle, die dieses Qualitätsmerkmal vergibt,
aber das ist trotzdem der Konsens aller anderer Parteien und so war relativ
klar, dass es keine Koalition unter Herbert Kickl geben konnte.
Und deswegen sind wir jetzt gerade in Verhandlungen zwischen ÖVP,
SPÖ und NEOS, den österreichischen Liberalen.
Kannst du nochmal kurz die Wahlergebnisse kurz in Zahlen?
Weil die FPÖ hat ja schon die meisten Stimmen bekommen und wäre von daher ja
eigentlich so der natürliche Regierungsbildner, aber warum mag denn den Herrn Kickl keiner?
Weil der Herr Kickl, was ist über den Herrn Kickl zu sagen, der hat so als Redenschreiber
von Jörg Haider angefangen,
von seiner Feder sind so Sätze wie der Ham statt Islam, Bummering statt Muezzin,
Bummering ist die Glocke am Stephansturm.
Und er ist auch derjenige, der bei diesen Ausrutschern, die Heider gemacht hat,
also Ausrutscher ist so schön formuliert, aber diesen Sagern,
die ihn wirklich auch in Bedrohliebe gebracht haben,
so im Dritten Reich, gab es eine ordentliche Beschäftigungspolitik und derartiges.
Also da war Herbert Kickl immer involviert,
er war oft in der zweiten Reihe, Dann als Innenminister unter der ÖVP-FPÖ-Regierung
war er Innenminister und das hat auch dazu geführt,
dass er eine Hausdurchsuchung im Inlandsgeheimdienst in Österreich ausführen
hat lassen und dort sehr interessiert an den Daten des Referats war,
das sich mit Rechtsextremismus beschäftigt.
Und ja, Herbert Kickl ist definitiv jemand, der Grundrechte und Rechtsstaatlichkeit
nicht wirklich wichtig sind.
Und gleichzeitig ist es so, obwohl die FPÖ mit 28,85 Prozent Stimmenstärkste Partei wurde,
es war nur 2 Prozent Abstand zur ÖVP mit 26 Prozent und dann die SPÖ mit 21 in dritter Stelle.
Und Liberale und Grüne haben jeweils so neun beziehungsweise acht Prozent bekommen.
Also die vorherige Regierung aus ÖVP und Grünen hätte damit keine Mehrheit mehr,
die wollen aber sowieso nicht weitermachen und man hätte natürlich jetzt unter
Führung der FPÖ eine Regierung bilden können,
nur dafür fand sich kein Partner.
Und in Österreich ist es so, dass der Bundespräsident Alexander Van der Bellen,
ehemals grüner Politiker, die Aufgabe hat, einen Regierungsbildungsauftrag zu vergeben.
Und den hat er nach diesen Runden, die es da gab zwischen den stimmenstärksten
Parteien, nicht an die FPÖ erteilt.
Da gibt es auch geteilte Meinungen im Land. Einige sagen, ja super,
genau dafür haben wir ihn gewählt, dass er die FPÖ verhindert,
weil da hat der Präsident in Österreich ein Beauvoir.
Andere meinen, das war undemokratisch und bei den kürzlichen Landtagswahlen in der Steiermark,
hat die FPÖ auch massiv zugelegt, sodass sie dort auch wieder stimmenstärkste
Partei wurde und jetzt auch den Landeshauptmann in der Steiermark stellen wird.
Also der Rechtsruck, den man ja in ganz vielen Ländern global sehen kann,
hat auch für Österreich nicht Halt gemacht.
Ja, seufzt es.
Ja, aber jetzt gibt es halt eben den Versuch einer Dreierkoalition,
sowas gab es in Österreich noch nie.
Und deswegen wollte ich auch mal so ein bisschen darüber reden,
wie sich das aus netzpolitischer Sicht darstellt. Also aus dem Nähkästchenplaudern.
Also welche drei sollen sie jetzt zusammen tun?
Die Konservativen, die ÖVP, die Sozialdemokraten, die SPÖ und die NEOS, die Liberalen.
Die drei probieren jetzt gar nicht mehr.
Bei den Verhandlungen geht es natürlich ganz viel auch um Budgetfragen,
Wirtschaftsschwäche, lauter Pleiten sind gerade in Österreich an oberster Stelle,
was die Nachrichten betrifft.
Da verlieren gerade viele Leute vor Weihnachten ihren Job.
Und gleichzeitig gibt es aber natürlich auch netzpolitische Themen,
die in der Regierung hoffentlich auch Beachtung finden und wo es wichtige Forderungen gibt.
Und als Epicenter Works, als
netzpolitischer NGO, wie geht man auf solche Koalitionsverhandlungen zu?
Ich glaube, das könnte ein paar Leute interessieren und das Wichtigste ist eigentlich
seine Forderungen relativ klar zu formulieren.
Und das ist das Einfache, dass man mal zusammenträgt, worum geht es uns eigentlich?
Was ist der Katalog an Dingen?
Das Schwierige ist dann, diesen Forderungen Relevanz und Nachdruck zu verschaffen.
Das ist ganz viel Klinkenputzen und gute Argumente erfinden,
wieso zum Beispiel jetzt für eine sozialdemokratische Partei gewisse Fragen
der Besteuerung von Digitalkonzernen wichtig sind.
Wieso du bei staatlicher Überwachung eher dagegen sein willst.
Bei Liberalen probierst du dann vielleicht im Bildungssegment gute Argumente
zu finden und man versucht halt sozusagen dann die eigenen Forderungen der Partei
schmackhaft zu machen und bestenfalls schafft man es schon, dass das Ganze in
die Wahlprogramme kommt.
Also noch bevor die Wahl überhaupt passiert, gibt es ja Wahlprogramme und wenn
da schon Forderungen drinnen sind, ist das schon sehr hilfreich.
Da hilft es auch immer, wenn man Koalitionen bindet. Wir haben es zum Beispiel geschafft.
Ein Recht auf analoges Leben in die Wahlprogramme der drei stimmenstärksten
Parteien, also SPÖ, ÖVP, FPÖ, reinzubekommen, gemeinsam mit den Pensionistenverbänden.
Wieso haben wir das geschafft? Weil Österreich hat ja ID Austria,
das ist unser Digital Identity System, was seit ein bisschen mehr als einem
Jahr auf der Matte steht und relativ weit verbreitet ist.
Und oh Wunder, alle möglichen Behörden haben angefangen, analoge Amtswege abzubauen
oder teurer zu machen und du kannst nur noch digital mit dem Amt kommunizieren.
Ist für Leute, die staatliche Identität ablehnen, ein Problem,
aber auch für diesen riesigen Block der älteren Menschen, die vielleicht überfordert
sind von digitaler Technik, teilweise gar kein Smartphone haben.
Und wenn man die auf seiner Seite bekommt, hat man natürlich ein sehr starkes, gewichtiges Argument.
Und jetzt hat man es geschafft, dass das Thema aufgenommen wurde im Wahlprogramm.
Die Parteien, die das gefordert haben, wurden auch gewählt.
Dann ist die wichtige Frage, wie bringt man das in den Verhandlungen durch?
Sobald du weißt, welche Arbeitsgruppen verhandeln und welche Personen da drinnen
sind, geht es auch wieder ans Klinkenputzen, ans Argumente erstellen,
so dass dabei am Ende dann auch das im Gesetz steht, was wir haben wollen.
Also dass Diskriminierungen zum Beispiel verboten werden.
Und das Thema wird jetzt alles noch verhandelt, wir haben noch kein Ergebnis,
damit rechnet man so wahrscheinlich eher nach Weihnachten, Anfang Jänner.
Aber auch hier gilt Forderungen aufnehmen zu lassen von den Verhandlern ist
einfach sie am Ende durchzubringen ist schwierig weil du gehst in solchen Verhandlungen
rein mit mehr Punkten als du eigentlich durchbringen willst,
du brauchst Verhandlungsmasse,
und du sagst dann so ja gebt mir alle eure Punkte und dann bist du halt in dem
Katalog an Dingen die einfach weggetradet werden dafür, dass man das bekommt
was man wirklich will also man muss es auch,
zur Priorität bei den Verhandler innen machen.
Und ich weiß zum Beispiel in Deutschland, als die derzeitige Ampelkoalition
verhandelt wurde, die hatten wirklich so vier Spalten Dokumente,
wo sie die Wahlprogramme nebeneinander hatten, damals ja von SPD, Grünen und FDP.
Und dann die vierte Spalte ist das Koalitionsabkommen, sozusagen der Text,
ob man sich einignt. Genau.
Ja und am Ende hat man dieses Koalitionsabkommen, das sind oft mehr als 100
Seiten und da geht es auch darum, die relativ flott zu analysieren in Ampelfarben, was davon ist gut,
was ist bedenklich und was ist gefährlich, sodass man auch für sich selber einen
Arbeitsplan hat und weiß,
wie ist dieses Ergebnis zu bewerten.
Nicht jeder wird diese hunderten Seiten lesen, aber die Leute sollen natürlich
informiert sein, was da auf sie zukommt in den nächsten Jahren.
Das ist so grob der Ablauf.
Und denkst du, es wird zu dieser Koalition kommen?
Gute Frage. Also dadurch, dass man so vehement abgelehnt hat,
mit Herbert Kickley und der FPÖ zu koalieren,
hängt die Zukunft von den Chefs, von den Konservativen und den Sozialdemokraten
ganz stark davon ab, dass diese Verhandlungen zu einem Ergebnis führen.
Gleichzeitig liegen die Parteien unheimlich weit auseinander.
Also man versucht ehrlich jetzt irgendwie sich zu einigen, aber in Österreich
ist auch ein riesiges Budgetloch. Man muss sparen.
Die Parteien sind sich total uneinig, wie man das tun soll, welche Steuern braucht
es, welche lehnt man aus ideologischen Gründen ab.
Und auch die Frage, wo gespart wird, ist natürlich eine, die immer an die Pründe
geht, wo es schwierig ist. Und deswegen, es wurden sogar Wahrscheinlichkeiten
ausgegeben und manche sagen sogar, also die ÖVP sagt 50-50.
Die Sozialdemokraten sagen 80-20, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Also sogar die, deren Karriere davon abhängt, sind jetzt nicht so 100 Prozent, das schaffen wir.
Es wäre natürlich gut fürs Land, wenn man die FPÖ aus der Regierung hält,
wenn es zu einer Koalition kommt,
die vielleicht ein paar Reformen durchbekommt, bevor sie explodiert.
Dass die die vollen fünf Jahre Legislaturperiode durchhalten,
halte ich für eher unwahrscheinlich.
Gibt es auch schon einen potenziellen Spitznamen für diese Art von Konstellation
aufgrund der Farbenmischung?
Also in Deutschland haben wir ja jetzt mit BSW wieder so neun Farbklicks und
jetzt kommen sie schon mit Schmetterlingskoalition und so weiter.
Das wird alles ein bisschen unübersichtlich.
Wieso stellst du diese Frage, Tim? Darüber wurde auch massiv diskutiert.
Das sind die Art von Medienberichten, die ich wegignoriere.
Das ist doch wichtig.
Wie soll man das sonst nennen?
Also es ist so von der Farbenlehre, wir haben halt schwarz, rot und pink.
Und das ist wirklich so dieses Hello Kitty Pink.
Das ist doch schön, die Hello Kitty Koalition. Das ist so das,
was wir schon immer gebraucht haben.
Ich mache jetzt wieder unser Land lächerlich, aber im Gespräch ist einerseits
die Zuckerl-Koalition oder Önzel, also Ampel mit Österreich, Önzel.
Auch besonders schlimm finde ich die Dirndl-Koalition.
Ich weiß nicht, welches Dirndl pink als Farbe hat, aber ich bin da auch kein Experte.
Dirndl, oh Gott. Also Hello Kitty-Koalition auf jeden Fall.
Das fände ich gut.
Da gibt man auf jeden Fall schon mal einen Bonus.
In die Verhandlung.
Da kann ja auch keiner so richtig böse sein, oder? Also Hello Kitty ist,
glaube ich, gut zur Beruhigung.
Ja, eben, genau. Das können die Leute auch wirklich mal gebrauchen.
Ringt euch mal ein bisschen ab.
Mein Gott, diese ganze Wut und Aufregung und so weiter. Ist doch alles nur fake induziert. Eure Wut.
Naja, okay. Gut, vielleicht bei allen.
Das war es zu Österreich. Also ich glaube, mehr gibt es gar nicht zu sagen.
Es wird dann spannend, wie es weitergehen wird in den Verhandlungen.
Wir werden berichten und entweder vor Weihnachten, aber realistischer erst Anfang
des Jahres 2025 gibt es dann ein Ergebnis. Gucken wir.
So spannend wird es aber auch in Europa.
Genau.
Es wird ja langsam Zeit, dass die neue Kommission sich aufstellt.
Ja, die neue Kommission ist bestellt. Jetzt Ende November hat das Europaparlament
seinen Sanctus gegeben und die Kommission von Ursula von der Leyen II ist inzwischen
schon im Amt und ich habe mir gedacht,
es könnte ganz spannend sein, sich mal das netzpolitische Personal hier näher anzuschauen.
Und es ist wieder die große Herausforderung, diese Namen richtig auszusprechen,
aber ich glaube Henna Virkunen aus Finnland ist sie auf jeden Fall zu nennen.
Sie ist verantwortlich für Tech Sovereignty, Security and Democracy.
Also sie kümmert sich um die digitalen Agenten. Sie ist die Nachfolgerin von
Thierry Breton aus Frankreich und dessen Vorgänger war Günther Oettinger aus
dem schönen Baden-Württemberg.
Ist das Ressort auch genauso?
Nein, das heißt immer anders. Tech Sovereignty war bisher noch nicht in dem
Titel, aber es gibt, de facto ist sie digitale Kommissarin und das zuständige
Haus, dem sie vorsteht, ist DigiConnect.
DigiConnect ist zuständig für die Digitalagenten.
Da drinnen liegt alles, wo es um Telekomagenten geht, um künstliche Intelligenz,
um alles, was Daten betrifft.
Und wobei nicht unbedingt Datenschutz, aber zum Beispiel Data Governance Act
und solche Sachen liegen da drinnen.
Also DigiConnect ist wirklich das größte Haus, die sich um alles kümmern wollen,
was irgendwie sozusagen in digitalen, originär digitalen Themen liegt.
Wir kommen noch zu den anderen zwei Häusern, die da auch relevant sind.
Sie fordert auch, also Hannah Vergunen fordert den Digital Networks Act.
Das ist ein Gesetz, was nur als direkter Angriff auf die Netzneutralität zu verstehen ist.
Sie übernimmt damit leider die Agenda von Thierry Pétain und sie wird hochrelevant sein für alles,
was Digitalgesetzgebung betrifft und in ihrem Hearing haben wir es geschafft,
so ein paar Fragen stellen zu lassen durch die Abgeordneten.
Und ja, es ist mäßig, aber man muss ja auch sagen, dass diese Kommission die
erste ist seit, glaube ich, den 90ern, wo die kompletten Vorschläge aus allen
Ländern angenommen wurden.
Man hat niemanden zurückgeschickt und das ist unüblich. Normalerweise wird wenigstens
eine Person rausgekickt, aber dieses Mal war das nicht so.
Von der Leyen hatte auch stärkere Zustimmungen für sich als Person nochmal Präsidentin
zu werden, als dann ihre finale Mannschaft.
Unter anderem zum Beispiel, weil der ungarische Kandidat besonders kontrovers war.
Es gibt da ja natürlich auch immer gewisse Personen, wo es Conflict of Interest geht.
Also das ist Henna Verkunen. Wen gibt es noch? Michael McGrath aus Irland.
Der ist zuständig für Democracy, Justice, the Rule of Law and Consumer Protection.
Also Demokratie, so etwas wie Justizministerium und Konsumentenschutz.
Sprich, er ist auch zuständig für DigiJust. Das ist sowas wie das Digitalisierungsministerium.
Da gehen ganz viele Gesetze durch. Unter anderem auch die DSGVO kommt aus diesem Ressort.
Und ich habe schon Max Schrems damit aufgezogen, dass es jetzt besonders bitter
ist, dass gerade jemand aus Irland für Rechtsstaatlichkeit verantwortlich ist, für Rule of Law.
Weil die Iren sind ja bekannt dafür, dass Irland mehr oder weniger das Schlupfloch
für die DSGVO ist und dass deren Geschäftsmodell es ja fast ist,
dass man Gesetze nicht durchsetzt gegen Großkonzerne.
Vor kurzem musste Irland vom EuGH dazu verklagt werden, Steuern anzunehmen von Apple.
Da gab es ja dieses Urteil 14 Milliarden Euro,
die Irland gar nicht haben wollte und der Euge Hart auf Bestreben von Margarete
Westdager dann halt eben festgestellt, doch doch, dass diese Steuertricks sind
illegal und nehmt jetzt diese 14 Milliarden.
Das ist wirklich hardcore. Also ich meine, das ist ja auch so ein generelles
Schlupfloch und da hat sich Apple, glaube ich, besonders bedient.
Beileibe nicht die einzigen, aber das war bei denen natürlich ganz klar.
Im Kern geht es ja um ihre ganzen Einnahmen, die sie hier machen mit den Apple Stores.
Also sie verkaufen ja hier quasi ihre Devices, aber haben sich halt immer rausgeredet
mit, naja, das ist ja alles amerikanisch produziert und so weiter.
Wir sind ja hier nur so ein Outlet und wir machen ja hier eigentlich gar nichts.
Und dann wurde, das hat Irland halt immer durchgehen lassen. Warum?
Weil Irland natürlich davon profitiert, diese ganzen Ansiedlungen zu haben.
Also es ist ja, in Irland treten sich ja alle auf die Füße. Facebook,
Apple, das haben wir schon öfter mal erwähnt die Liste ist relativ lang es geht ja auch Irland.
Gerade richtig gut, also das ist ja ein Land, was einen wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung
jetzt über sehr lange Zeit schon hat so sehr im Übrigen, dass dieser wirtschaftliche
Aufschwung selbst ein Problem ist für das Land,
weil so viele Leute,
nach Irland migrieren, also es gibt da eine extreme Zuwanderung,
gerade in Irland Und zwar einfach, weil der Arbeitsplatzbedarf so hoch ist von diesen Unternehmen.
Und das bedeutet, dass hier aus ganz Europa, vor allem, nicht nur,
aber wahrscheinlich vor allem aus Europa, Leute jetzt nach Irland ziehen,
sehr viele natürlich dann auch nach Dublin, auch wenn ein paar andere Regionen
davon betroffen sind und es einfach gar nicht genug Housing gibt.
Dadurch steigen natürlich die Preise enorm.
Das kennen wir hier in Berlin auch, diesen Effekt.
Und das ist dann natürlich wiederum für viele Leute ein Problem etc.
Pp. Trotzdem hält Irland halt politisch an dieser Politik fest,
die halt eine Politik der niedrigen Besteuerung ist.
Ich meine, man kann das natürlich auch verstehen und in gewisser Hinsicht ist es ja auch legitim.
Die Staaten haben ja die Möglichkeit, ihre Steuern selber festzulegen.
Und durch diese niedrige Unternehmensbesteuerung haben sie natürlich Ansiedlungen
rangeholt als Zugangsland für die EU,
die unterm Strich, kann man ja sagen, sehr erfolgreich für das Land eben auch
einen wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung gebracht haben.
Jetzt wissen sie gar nicht so richtig wohin mit ihrem Geld.
Trotzdem geht das natürlich hier auf Kosten aller, weil wenn einfach da diese
Besteuerung so niedrig ausfällt, dass dann ja sozusagen auch für alle nichts übrig bleibt.
Es geht ja nicht nur um Irland, sondern geht ja im Kern auch um die Beiträge
für die EU und insofern ist es ganz sinnvoll, dass diese Entscheidung uns so gefallen ist.
Absolut und ich stimme allem zu, was du gesagt hast über die Situation in Irland.
Da gibt es auch eine große Schere zwischen diesen Migrantinnen,
die man ja Expats nennt, wenn sie reich sind.
Und weiß.
Genau. Und auf der anderen Seite die Realität der Irinnen und Iren,
die sich halt wirklich oft das Leben und die Wohnungen nicht mehr leisten können.
Also ich würde diesen Wohlstand in dem Land so ein bisschen in Frage stellen,
aber da ist auch viel, was wirklich Irland selber zu regeln hat,
nur aus europäischer Perspektive kann es halt nicht sein,
dass du ein Land hast, wo das Nicht-Einhalten von EU-Gesetzen der Ansiedlungsvorteil
ist und damit auch der Wettbewerbsvorteil dieses Landes.
Und das ist ein rechtsstaatliches Problem,
wenn du einfach weißt, dieses Gesetz kannst du umgehen, indem du dich in Irland
ansiedelst, wo Common Law gilt,
wo es so gut wie unmöglich ist, dass Behörden ihren Job machen und Gerichte
sauber und mit vertretbarem Aufwand die Erklärung zu Sachfragen liefern.
Also das sieht man ja auch beim Digital Services Act, wo wir klar schon auf
EU-Ebene vorgebaut haben, weil man gar nicht mehr daran glaubt,
dass Irland diese Gesetze gegenüber den Plattformen, die dort angesiedelt sind, durchsetzen wird.
Also da ist es halt einfach ein Treppenwitz, dass dann Michael McGrath aus Irland
genau für Rule of Law und Rechtsstaatlichkeit zuständig ist.
Ja, kommen wir weiter. Es gibt noch eine andere Personalie und zwar aus Österreich.
Magnus Brunner, der ist zuständig für Internal Affairs and Migration.
Also er ist so etwas wie ein europäischer Innenminister.
Und in Österreich war er zuständig für das Finanzministerium.
Davor war er Staatssekretär im Klimaministerium zuständig für Luftverkehr und
jetzt hat er dieses für ihn selber auch überraschende Portfolio bekommen,
einerseits eben Innenminister,
aber dann auch zuständig für das sehr heikle Thema Migration in der EU.
Man muss dazu sagen, er ist aus der ÖVP.
Genau, ja. Er ist aus der ÖVP, die zu dem Zeitpunkt der EU-Wahl auch stimmenstärkste
Partei in Österreich war. Das ist ja aktuell nicht mehr so.
Und was das bedeutet aus netzpolitischer Sicht ist, dass Magnus Brunner auch
zuständig sein wird für die Chat-Kontrolle.
Die ist ja von der jetzigen Innenministerin der EU-Kommission vorgestellt worden
und deren Agenden beerbt er.
Und auch etwaige weitere Überwachungsgesetze werden dann unter seiner Ägide.
Und man munkelt ja, dass es einen neuen Anlauf zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung geben sollte.
Auch über Staatstrojaner-Gesetzgebung wird geredet.
Bundestrojaner in Österreich, wie wir sagen.
Ja, Magnus Brunner ist aus Vorarlberg, also aus dem westlichsten Bundesland
in Österreich und sehr lange dient der ÖVP-Kader.
Es gibt aber auch gute Meinungen zu ihm, also er scheint nicht die schlechteste
Wahl gewesen zu sein innerhalb der ÖVP und wie er sich jetzt aber mit diesen
Portfolios tun wird, ist die große Frage.
Aber das ist sozusagen auch die österreichische Note. Man merkt auch so ein
bisschen den Humor von Ursula von der Leyen.
Österreich zählt ja zu den Ländern, die bei Migrationsfragen immer ausscheren
gegen den EU-Kompromiss und da auch so in eine ungarische Richtung gehen.
Und dass dann genau jemand aus so einem Land zuständig ist dafür,
die EU-Regeln in diesem Bereich durchzusetzen, ist genau die Art von Humor, die sie mag.
Und ist dann noch so, eat your own dog food.
Man könnte auch sagen, der Bereich, wo die Leute am wenigsten Kompetenz oder
Haltung haben, ist, wo sie Zuständigkeit bekommen, ist.
Also das ist die neue EU-Kommission, was ihr Personal betrifft.
Was den Arbeitsplan angeht, also das, was wir vorher auf nationaler Ebene das
Koalitionsabkommen nennen, das werden wir Anfang Jänner bekommen.
Also ab Anfang Jänner wissen wir hoffentlich relativ genau, mit welchen Gesetzen
oder Themen wir rechnen müssen.
Und das heißt, ab Jänner kann man sich dann auch vorbereiten für die nächsten
viereinhalb Jahre Legislaturperiode auf EU-Ebene, was da alles noch in Grauslichkeiten kommen wird.
Grob ein Drittel der EU-Kommission sind Frauen, wenn ich das richtig gezählt habe gerade.
Es war ja glaube ich ein Ziel von Ursula von der Leyen, da die Quote zu erhöhen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sie vorher war, aber bei 50-50 sind wir jetzt doch noch nicht angekommen.
Ja, sie wollte auch, dass nachgebessert wird in diesem Punkt,
hat da extra auch nochmal den Leuten gesagt, wenn ihr Frauen schickt,
kriegen die höhere Posten.
Aber darauf hat sich, glaube ich, nur ein Land eingelassen.
Alle anderen haben argumentiert, na, das ist doch wer, den wir mögen,
der hat jetzt gerade schon seinen anderen Job gekündigt, wir haben niemand anderen.
Ja, also das ist probiert worden und auf sehr blamable Weise gescheitert.
Okay, ich freue mich allerdings sehr über Kaya Callas,
die ja für die Security Policy,
quasi das Außenministerium der EU-Kommission besetzt,
ehemalige Ministerpräsidentin von Estland und auch die erste Frau in der Rolle
und die hat ja ziemlich einen Eindruck gemacht damals.
Also ich glaube, das ist eine Top-Besetzung gerade in der aktuellen Situation.
Schauen wir mal, wie die so performt im netzpolitischen Bereich,
glaube ich, ist weiterhin mit viel Gegenwind zu rechnen.
Ja, die Arbeit geht uns nicht aus.
Aber Tim, gehen wir weiter. Von Österreich nach Australien.
Ja, das ist ja ein Katzensprung.
From cows to kangaroos. Was ist da passiert?
Ja, was da passiert. Ja, in Australien ist jetzt tatsächlich ein Gesetz verabschiedet worden,
was unter 16-Jährigen den Zugang zu Social Media verbietet.
Tatsächlich. Also es ist jetzt da wirklich Gesetz, beziehungsweise es ist jetzt beschlossen.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ab wann das Gesetz gilt, aber ich vermute mal Anfang
des Jahres dürfte das schon soweit sein.
Und das verbietet tatsächlich einfach quasi das Posten auf Social Media.
Das ist natürlich die Frage, was ist die Definition davon.
Es ist auch ein richtiges Verbot, also es ist keine Empfehlung oder so.
Also das dürfen auch die Eltern nicht overriden.
Also es ist kein Einverständnis der Eltern, könnte das in irgendeiner Form ändern.
Und Schuld sind die Plattformen selber.
Das heißt, die müssen sicherstellen, dass eben auch australische Jugendliche unter 16 nicht posten.
Und wenn sie das dann tun, dann böse und dann gibt es auch Millionenstrafen.
Was wiederum bedeutet, dass diese Plattformen gezwungen sind,
in irgendeiner Form eine Altersverifikation vorzunehmen und da sind wir natürlich
dann bei dem eigentlichen Thema.
Also abgesehen von der Metafrage, ist denn das richtig oder wird das dann auch
sozusagen den gewünschten Effekt haben, stellt sich natürlich dann hier auch
so eine technologische Frage.
Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist ja aber die technische Umsetzung dieser Altersverifikation
noch nicht mal richtig geklärt, oder?
Ja, das ist sowieso immer bei dieser Debatte der Fall.
Leute kommen auf die glamouröse Idee, dass man ja irgendwas wegen den Kindern
tun muss und dann ist die Antwort immer Stoppschilder aufzustellen.
Zumindest ist das in den meisten Ländern so die Lösung. In Deutschland gibt
es ja auch so den Ansatz, dann soziale Netzwerke nur für unter 16,
18, 12-Jährige zu machen, wo ich auch die Sinnfrage stellen würde.
Aber mit welchen technischen Mitteln man dann das Alter der UserInnen bestimmen will, ist total offen.
Und auch hier wieder in Australien hat der Gesetzgeber einfach gesagt,
ja, da werden wir uns schon was einfallen lassen. Aber wir beschließen das Gesetz jetzt trotzdem.
Und das ist aus einer netzpolitischen Sicht natürlich desaströs.
Und es gibt hier natürlich auch viele sehr gefährliche Optionen.
Instagram vom Metakonzern hat hier KI-basierte Lösungen entwickelt,
die halt einfach mit Gesichtserkennung versuchen, das Alter zu schätzen.
Natürlich kann man es auch anhand des Nutzungsverhalten raten,
aber das ist halt nur geraten.
Und im Kern ist auch die Frage, über welches Gerät kann denn dieser Altersnachweis
erfüllt werden, weil gerade junge Kinder haben ja auch aus gutem Grund noch
kein Smartphone und auch wenn sie eines hätten,
die Erziehungsberechtigten sind ja die Legal Guardians, das heißt die haben
dann auch die staatliche Identität von ihren schutzbefohlenen Kindern auf deren Gerät.
Das heißt, wenn man die Erwachsenen aussperren will, funktioniert auch das natürlich wiederum nicht.
Also hier stellen sich ganz viele Fragen aus meiner Sicht. Was ist so der Trust Anchor?
Gut, wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein Melderegister hast, kannst du es an das knüpfen
und wenn dann auch Ausweisdokumente vorliegen, gibt es sicherlich Wege,
wie du damit das Onboarding, das Enrollment machen kannst für eine digitale Identität.
Ich glaube, in Deutschland sind da jetzt auch irgendwie die Kinderärztinnen
und Ärzte oder die Schulen im Gespräch, dass man es darüber ausrollt.
Ob das wirklich flächendeckend funktionieren wird, kann ich nicht sagen,
aber da habe ich meine Zweifel.
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall ein super harter Schritt, hier einfach zu sagen,
Kinder und Jugendliche dürfen soziale Netzwerke nicht mehr verwenden.
Ich glaube, das geht an der Lebensrealität vorbei und das erinnert mich so ein
bisschen an Sexualerziehung, die halt einfach den Jugendlichen sagt,
tut es nicht, bis es zu spät ist.
Und das ist kein Erziehen für den
selbstbestimmten Umgang zur Nutzung des Internets und digitaler Technik.
Genau, also ich sehe hier gleich mehrere Probleme. Das erste ist natürlich erstmal,
was ist überhaupt genau gemeint mit Social Media und welche Dienste qualifizieren
jetzt unter diesem Begriff und welche nicht,
weil es ist nämlich jetzt nicht so, dass, also meine.
Da hätten wir, glaube ich, schon Probleme, das zu beantworten, was ist Social Media.
Ich meine, es gibt jetzt so das klassische Social Media, was halt so Facebook, Twitter.
Mastodon, Blue Sky, diese ganzen textbasierten Dinger, Instagram,
Timeline durchscrollen, TikTok, Snapchat.
Das sind so die offensichtlichen und das sind auch, glaube ich,
die Dienste, die tatsächlich konkret von diesem Gesetz auch betroffen sind.
Aber dann gibt es halt auch sowas wie WhatsApp, also Messenger-Dienste,
die wiederum nicht davon betroffen sind, was wahrscheinlich auch zum sofortigen
Zusammenbruch von Schulverteilern führen würde,
die heutzutage wahrscheinlich durchgehend auf Messenger-Plattformen gemacht werden.
Nur wissen wir alle, dass auch diese Messenger in zunehmendem Maße dieselben
Ausprägungsformen haben, die auch Social Media hat.
Das ist bei Telegram ganz stark, aber es ist natürlich auch bei WhatsApp in
dem Moment, wo man öffentliche Gruppen hat, ist das natürlich auch ein Social Medium.
Und dann kannst du da das sozusagen tun, aber woanders nicht.
Also da fängt es an schon zu brechen. Genauso haben sie dann Online-Gaming-Plattformen
auch rausgenommen und auch YouTube, was definitiv ja auch Social Media ist.
YouTube konsumieren und auf YouTube posten ist ja dann auch nochmal ein bisschen was anderes.
Aber YouTube Shorts ist genauso wie TikTok eigentlich.
Exactly, genau. Und also die Übergänge sind da extrem fließend und ja,
ich bin jetzt natürlich im Wortlaut des Gesetzes nicht vertraut,
wie es im Einzelnen das jetzt alles regelt, aber es gibt halt so Ausnahmen für
schulische Zwecke und so weiter.
Also am Ende, glaube ich, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das allein schon auf
der Ebene scheitert, beziehungsweise zu einem Shift führt,
ja, also einem Nutzungsshift hin zu Messenger-Plattformen, hin zu YouTube,
also was auch immer ausgenommen ist,
wird quasi diesen Druck, der natürlich von den Jugendlichen ausgeht, auffangen und.
Und wir werden sozusagen sehen,
dass dann eben entsprechende Angebote dann eben woanders zu finden ist.
Das ist schon mal das eine. Das andere ist natürlich diese Frage mit,
ist es überhaupt angemessen, so ein Verbot auszusprechen.
Weil ja die Annahme ist, das ist alles böse und da wird nur Schindluder getrieben
und das Ganze ist für euch eine Bedrohung. Und das ist es natürlich auch teilweise.
Also ich meine, wir kennen alle die Diskussionen, die sind ja auch nicht neu
und die sind auch nicht falsch, dass man sieht, wie Kids dort einfach mit,
das fängt schon an halt mit so falschen Rollenbildern, das ist ja eher so eine
Metadiskussion, aber eben auch konkret einfach versucht werden,
ihnen irgendwie was aufzudrücken, was sie kaufen sollen.
Diese Challenges haben sich ja auch immer wieder als hochproblematisch herausgestellt,
die dann teilweise Leute auch wirklich gefährdet, weil junge Leute halt dazu.
Motiviert werden, irgendwas super gefährliches zu tun, bei dem dann eben manche
auch teilweise ums Leben gekommen oder anders zu Schaden gekommen sind.
Und das, wie heißt es so schön, Grooming,
also dass sozusagen Jugendlichen dort auch von meistens Männern aufgelauert
wird, auch das ist natürlich ein Problem,
was aber das Internet an sich hat, was jetzt nicht unbedingt nur ein Problem von Social Media ist.
Und ich kann immer sehr gut verstehen, wenn es solche Bewegungen gibt mit,
oh ja, da müssen wir ja mal was gegen tun und wir werden der Sache nicht her
und uns fällt jetzt nichts anderes ein, als die Tür komplett zuzuschlagen.
Es ist wirklich schwierig. Zumal, und das wird ja auch in den Artikeln,
die darüber berichten, auch immer wieder rausgestellt,
es ist ja auch nicht so, dass das nur dazu führt, dass Leute in die Depressionen
und in Selbstmord getrieben werden,
sondern für viele sind ja diese Medien auch wiederum genau eine Flucht,
weil du eben darüber Kontakt mit anderen Gruppen haben kannst.
Weil du darüber, wenn du selber irgendeiner verfolgten oder unterdrückten Minderheit
angehörst oder sagen wir mal, vielleicht ein bisschen zu hartes Wort,
aber wenn du, sagen wir mal, Probleme hast,
die nicht von all deinen Freunden geteilt werden,
queere Menschen etc., solche Gruppen, die dadurch natürlich dann auch schnell
in Netzwerke und in Freundeskreise eintreten können,
die eben zunächst einmal für sie nur über das Internet erreichbar sind und ihnen
damit eben auch Halt geben.
Das nimmt man ihnen dann ja dann auch wieder weg. 16 Jahre ist natürlich was,
also 16 ist schon recht hoch,
wenn man sich anschaut, wo die Nutzung heute so losgeht und sicherlich kann
man auch an dem Alter allein nicht genau festmachen,
wie reif jetzt irgendeine Person ist, sich mit diesem auszusetzen.
Auf der anderen Seite wissen wir ja auch.
Du wirst im Internet, wie auch im restlichen Leben im Übrigen,
du wirst nicht vor allem beschützt werden können.
Und ein Teil der eigenen Resilienz ist einfach Erfahrung. Das ist nichts,
was einfach mit einem bestimmten Alter einsetzt.
So, ah, jetzt bin ich 16, jetzt bin ich irgendwie unverführbar und kann allen
Stereotypen meine eigene Meinung entgegenhalten, so funktioniert das ja nicht.
Sondern du musst halt deine Erfahrungen machen und ich denke,
es ist eben sehr viel sinnvoller, darüber nachzudenken,
wie man eben diesen Erfahrungsgewinn sinnvoll begleiten kann,
als mit so einem relativ plumpen Verbot, was einfach sagt so, ja,
wir ziehen jetzt hier einfach mal eine Linie mit Alter und mit irgendwie den
Apps, die wir jetzt gerade am meisten hassen und dann passt das schon irgendwie.
Und dann haben wir mal was getan.
Ob das dann messbare Erfolge bringen wird langfristig, da bin ich doch im Zweifel.
Bin ich auch. Also ich muss gestehen, dass es aus meiner Sicht schon so ein
bisschen diese Anmutung hat, wir verbieten, was wir nicht verstehen.
Boomer, so wurde es auch von einer Abgeordneten im australischen Parlament genannt,
die Boomer verbieten halt einfach, was für sie Alien ist und drücken damit eigentlich
nur ihr Unverständnis über das Nutzungsverhalten von Kindern und Jugendlichen aus.
Also ich glaube, da hätte es zielgerichtetere Maßnahme gegeben,
also ein Totalverbot, das geht aus meiner Sicht klar zu weit und ist auch ein
Grundrechtseingriff, der die Rechte von Kindern und Jugendlichen zu stark beschränkt.
Ich prophezeie mal, dass die Nutzung von VPNs und TOR in Australien stark nach
oben gehen wird, weil Kinder sind nicht dumm und gerade das Verbotene und Gefährliche ist ja,
was man spannend findet in diesem Alter.
Also ich glaube, viele werden sich davon eh nicht abhalten lassen,
aber halt gerade da, wo vielleicht dieses Wissen nicht so weit verbreitet ist,
kann es dann schon sein, dass jemand, der vielleicht queer ist und diese Netzwerke
wirklich gebraucht hätte für seine persönliche Entwicklung, davon ausgeschlossen ist.
Aber ich tue mir bei dieser generellen Frage, wie man mit Jugendschutz im Internet
umgeht, auch so ein bisschen schwer. Ich habe keine Kinder.
Es ist für mich ein Thema, wo es durchaus eine Palette an interessanten Maßnahmen
gibt, die man treffen kann.
Ich finde zum Beispiel diesen Trend in den USA, Smartphones aus den Schulen
zu verbannen während dem Unterricht.
Das ist zumindest mal was, das man sich anschauen kann. Ich weiß nicht, wie das jetzt wirkt.
Da wird es hoffentlich auch bald Daten geben, aber das ist eine interessante Bewegung.
Ja und in Deutschland gibt es ja auch eine App, die Jugendschutz oder Altersverifikation
für Jugendschutz möglich machen soll.
Da hat mir Khaleesi erzählt, dass das im Dezember vorgestellt wird vom Ministerium,
aber da kann sie sicherlich mehr dazu sagen. und in Europa haben wir auch eine
App zur Altersverifikation, wo es eine Ausschreibung der EU-Kommission gibt.
Fünf Millionen sind dafür eingeplant und natürlich ist das alles auch etwas,
das mit EIDAS am Ende zu lösen sein wird.
Also die European Digital Identity Wallet, wo wir jetzt ja auch wissen, dass die bis zum 28.
November 2026 kommen muss, die wird sicherlich auch ein Tool sein,
um so Altersverifikations-Use-Cases abzudecken.
Und da wollte ich nochmal so aus netzpolitischer Sicht was dazu sagen,
weil so unsicher ich mir bin, was die richtigen Tools sind, um da das Beste
für die Kinder und Jugendlichen herauszubekommen.
Bei Datenschutzfragen, glaube ich, haben wir eine Lösung.
Also wie wir solche Systeme in ihrem User-Interface bauen können und in ihrer
technischen Architektur, sodass da einfach kein Datenschutznachteil für die User entsteht.
Und das wären halt die drei Hauptanforderungen, dass das Ganze unbeobachtbar ist.
Sprich, dass der Staat nicht zuschauen kann, wenn ich mich bei Social Media
einlogge oder wenn ich irgendwas mit diesem Werkzeug tue.
Sie müssen unlinkable sein. Also so, dass wenn ich mich jetzt mehrmals ausweise,
weil ich Zigaretten kaufe, weil ich eben irgendein soziales Netzwerk verwende,
dass das von mir verlangt, sind diese verschiedenen Interaktionen nicht miteinander korrelierbar.
Also sowohl für die einzelnen Reliant Party als auch über verschiedene Reliant
Partys hinweg und auch wenn der Staat da kolluden würde, also mit im Boot wäre,
dürfte man das nicht miteinander in Verbindung setzen können und das geht technisch heutzutage.
Und zuletzt Zero Knowledge, also dass ich halt nur übertrage,
dass ich über oder unter einem gewissen Alter bin, aber nicht mein Geburtsdatum.
All das führt dazu, dass diese Interaktionen wirklich nur so One-Time-Interactions
sind und natürlich kann ich dann auch das Telefon eines Elternteils verwenden,
weil die Gegenseite weiß dann eben nicht,
ist das die Verifikation von dem Menschen, der vor mir steht,
da gibt es kein Passfoto, was übertragen wird, Da gibt es kein User-Binding in irgendeiner Form.
Aber das wäre für diesen Anwendungsfall aus meiner Sicht mal die richtigen Privacy-by-Design-Kriterien,
um den Datenschutz-Impact zumindest zu minimieren.
Ob das insgesamt sinnvoll ist, steht auf einem anderen Blatt.
Mich erinnert das auch sehr an diese ganze Frage des Contact Tracings,
wo es ja auch so war, ob das epidemiologisch sinnvoll ist, müssen andere entscheiden.
Aber als Netzpolitik, finde ich, können wir die Datenschutzstandards aufstellen,
um dieses Thema zumindest aus der Debatte zu neutralisieren, soweit es geht.
Ja, das bringt uns dann doch vielleicht auch zum nächsten Thema, nämlich diese EIDAS.
Du bist ja ja auch involviert in diesem Prozess.
Was ist denn da der Stand der Dinge eigentlich?
Ja, kurzes Recap.
Die EIDAS-Reform hat 2021 gestartet,
war für uns von Anfang an ein Riesenthema, ist eigentlich im Mai 2024 final
beschlossen worden und veröffentlicht im Amtsblatt. Das Gesetz gilt auch schon.
Aber es ist so ein bisschen ein Sonderfall, dass es jetzt seit einigen Jahren
bei EU-Gesetzen immer diesen Trend gibt, dann gewisse Fragen erst mit Implementing Acts zu regeln.
Implementing Acts kennt man im deutschsprachigen Rechtssystem als Verordnungen
oder Durchführungsrechtsakte und das sind sozusagen Gesetze.
Und Rechtsakte, die nicht mehr durchs Parlament müssen, sondern einfach nur
auf kurzen Dienstweg von der
Kommission unter Einbeziehung der Mitgliedstaaten verabschiedet werden.
Und diese Implementing Acts sind deswegen hier sehr wichtig,
weil sie die ganzen technischen Details regeln.
Und die sind für Identifikation über digitale Wege natürlich super entscheidend.
Und wir haben jetzt am 21.
November die Implementing Acts zu dem, der erste Batch davon,
also die ersten fünf sind beschlossen worden.
Die kümmern sich genau um die Wallet. Also wie funktioniert die Wallet technisch?
Was sind die Standards, die ja verpflichtend sind, sodass das Ganze ja auch
grenzüberschreitend funktioniert?
Welche Garantien haben wir aus Usersicht? Wo ist sozusagen auch eine verpflichtende
Information vorgesehen?
Wenn jemand was von mir wissen will, werde ich gewarnt, wenn die über die Dinge
hinausgehen, die sie erfragen dürfen?
Die müssen sich ja alle registrieren, sowohl staatliche Stellen wie auch Firmen.
Und all das ist jetzt sozusagen mal im ersten Schwall geregelt worden.
Und da gibt es auch ein relativ gutes Ergebnis. Also die von mir vorher angesprochene
Unbeobachtbarkeit haben wir, soweit es im Rahmen des Gesetzes möglich war, drinnen.
Also der Staat darf nicht mir bei jeder Transaktion zuschauen.
Der darf das nur einsehen, wenn ich meine informierte Zustimmung gegeben habe
oder wenn es für den Betrieb des gesamten Dienstes notwendig ist.
Also wenn er jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwelche Telemetriedaten abfangen will, könnte das gehen.
Das ist nicht die perfekte Lösung, aber es ist was im Rahmen des Gesetzes machbar war.
Unlinkability haben wir auch relativ stark drinnen.
Selective Disclosure, das bedeutet, dass wenn ich eine Anfrage bekomme,
Informationen über mich preiszugeben, kann ich nicht nur Ja oder Nein klicken,
sondern auch sagen, ich gebe dir meinen Namen, aber nicht meine Adresse zum Beispiel.
Wir haben ein Recht auf Pseudonymität da drinnen. Das ist ganz wichtig,
weil die EIDAS-Wallet wird ja verwendet, wenn ich ein Bankkonto aufmache,
wo ich mich identifizieren muss, weil da gibt es ein Gesetz dazu,
es gibt keine anonymen Bankkonten mehr, aber sie wird auch verwendet,
um mich bei Facebook einzuloggen.
Ist sogar gesetzlich verpflichtet. Und da will ich natürlich ein Pseudonym verwenden,
das ist auch nochmal, soweit es geht, abgesichert im Gesetz.
Und bei dieser Frage Use Case Regulation, also darf mich jeder alles fragen,
darf ich bei einem Motel 1 Check-in gefragt werden nach meinem Familienstatus
oder nicht, da haben wir eigentlich zumindest eine Warnung reinbekommen.
Also der User wird gewarnt, hey, die fragen gerade mehr von dir an,
als sie dürfen und dann kannst du dich beschweren und das ist illegal nach Gesetz.
Dieses Model 1 könnte dann rausfliegen aus dem AI, das Ökosystem.
Aber genau bei diesem letzten Punkt wird gerade nochmal gestritten,
weil seit letzter Woche haben wir den nächsten Batch on Implementing Acts.
Der ist gerade zur Konsultation offen. Wir verlinken auch, wo man sich hier
einbringen kann. Und wir haben das schon getan als Epicenter Works und haben
uns sehr aufgeregt, dass das gegen den Kompromiss geht, den man vorher beschlossen hat.
Also gerade diese Debatte, darf ich mich bei Facebook Mickey Mouse nennen oder
dürfen die alles anfragen?
Die haben sich auf eine sehr perfide Art und Weise gelöst. Welche?
Es gibt sozusagen die Warnung an die User, die ist verpflichtet.
Diese Warnung wird aufgesprochen auf Basis von sogenannter Registration Certificates.
Also wenn du registriert bist als Firma oder staatliche Stelle,
musst du angeben, was willst du von den Leuten wissen und nur das,
was du da angibst in der Registrierung, darfst du dann fragen.
Ob du diese Zertifikate ausstellst, obliegt wieder dem Mitgliedstaat.
Das heißt, Facebook Irland wird natürlich keine solche Zertifikate haben und
darf dann alles von allen abfragen.
Das ist ein ziemlicher Wahnsinn, wie die Kommission sich das vorstellt.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie mit dem Durchkommen werden.
Also wir haben ja davor schon dreimal eine Abstimmung verhindert,
weil wir mit Mitgliedstaaten so eine Blocking Minority hatten.
Und da war auch Deutschland dabei, die haben gesagt, das ist nicht gut genug, ihr müsst nachbessern.
Da gab es drei Runden an Verhandlungen und zuletzt haben sie mehr oder weniger
Copy-Paste von unseren Änderungsanträgen gemacht und es war dann klar,
okay, gut, da können wir zustimmen.
Und jetzt bei der nächsten Sitzung
am 11. Dezember werden diese neuen Durchführungsrechtsakte diskutiert.
Bis zum 18. Dezember können Mitgliedstaaten Änderungen einmelden.
Leute aus der Zivilgesellschaft und der Wissenschaft können bis Ende Dezember
noch schriftlich ihr Feedback abgeben und dann rechnen wir mit einer Entscheidung Anfang nächstes Jahr.
Und das ist dann auch so der größte Teil dieser Implementing Acts,
der damit abgeschlossen ist. Und auf Basis dieser Durchführungsrechtsakte wird dann bis zum 28.
November 2026, spätestens dann müssen Mitgliedstaaten mindestens eine European
Digital Identity Wallet ihrer Bevölkerung anbieten.
Das heißt, es bleibt spannend, wir bleiben da auch dran, aber über ein paar
Sachen wird jetzt einfach noch gestritten.
Sollen wir mal das Datum, bis wann muss es?
Die Konsultation ist bis Ende Dezember online. Ich klicke auf den Link, den wir auch verlinken.
Na, sogar bis 2. Jänner. Also wer nach Silvester noch irgendein Feedback geben
will, kann das. Bis zum 2.
Jänner, Mitternacht, Brüsseler Time, kannst du noch dich äußern auf der Have
Your Say-Webseite der EU-Kommission.
Und unsere Einreichung ist auch verlinkt. Wir haben auch Änderungsanträge gemacht,
machen wir immer bei so wichtigen Sachen und dann eben die wirkliche finale
Deadline, bis die Wallet angeboten werden muss, die läuft schon.
Es sind zwei Jahre nach der Verabschiedung des ersten Badges, also 28. November 2026.
Ja, naja, also ich meine, Ja, den Chill Wallet, das ist natürlich echt so ein Thema.
Also ich bin ja, du bist ja sozusagen, also vielleicht kannst du ja nochmal
kurz deine Rolle nochmal erklären in diesem Prozess.
Also wir sind von Anfang an halt einfach so die NGO, die sich am meisten mit dem Thema beschäftigt.
Presenter Works arbeitet ja immer an dem, wo es technisch und rechtlich wird
und das ist es eindeutig hier.
Digital Identity beschäftigt uns seit 2017 und uns war klar,
das EU-System kann ein großer Wurf werden und das braucht Public Scrutiny und
einfach eine kritische Zivilgesellschaft, die drauf schaut und sagt, was nicht passt.
Das ist die Rolle und das Selbstverständnis.
Ich bin dann in Runden drinnen, wo zum Beispiel die Europäische Kommission hat
eine Expert Working Group, wo wir über solche technischen Standards reden.
Das ist einfach nur ein neuer Weg, dieselben Sachen zu sagen,
wo du dann halt Runden mit der Kommission hast.
Es gibt relativ viele Mitgliedstaaten, mit denen wir im Austausch sind,
weil auch die Niederlanden, Deutschland, Belgien, Österreich,
Tschechien, denen ist Datenschutz wichtig.
Mit denen kann man da über Dinge reden.
Auch Frankreich ist hier eigentlich relativ positiv.
Und ja, zuletzt bin ich auch noch in der Jury für die deutsche Wolle.
Die SPRINT, die Agentur für SPRINT-Innovation
hat da auch so ein Gremium ausgelotst, wo wir entscheiden,
wie die deutsche Wallet-Prototypen ausschauen sollen und da bin ich der einzige
Vertreter der Zivilgesellschaft drinnen in einem Jury von, glaube ich,
acht oder zehn Leuten sind wir. Nächste Woche am 10.
Dezember ist die letzte Sitzung, wo wir dann diese Firmen, die sich bewerben,
die deutsche Wallet zu werden, nochmal reduzieren von vier auf zwei Anbieter,
jeweils in einem Funded und Non-Funded Track.
Also es gibt so kleine Firmen, die wollen Geld vom deutschen Staat dafür,
dass sie einen Open-Source-Wallet-Prototypen bauen.
Und es gibt auch große Firmen, darunter auch Google, die in dem Non-Funded-Track
versuchen, hier die Wallet zu bauen.
Es gibt auch, wenn man auf der Webseite der Sprint nachschaut,
eine Dissenting Opinion eines Jurors, was Google betrifft, aufgrund von Marktmachts-
und Datenschutzbedenken.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall nächste Woche die letzte Sitzung und mal schauen, wie das ausgehen wird.
Aber das ist sozusagen die technologische Basis für das, was der deutsche Staat anbieten wird,
um eben im Zuge der nächsten zwei Jahre eine Bullet auf den Weg zu bringen,
wo ich auch hoffe, dass die kritische, netzpolitische Hacker-Szene sich das
sehr genau anschauen wird.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ein bisschen gespalten, was diese ganze Geschichte betrifft, weil ich ja denke,
so eine Identity-Geschichte müsste eigentlich tief in diesen Devices mit all
ihren Sicherheitsmechanismen verankert sein.
Ja, also so wie ich auch meine Kreditkartenzahlung autorisiere,
abgesichert eben durch Mechanismen des Betriebssystems mit Nutzung von so Secure Enclaves,
also speziell gesicherten, hardwaremäßig gesicherten Schlüsselspeichern im Prozessor,
auf die eben jetzt auch nicht jeder zugreifen kann, damit es eben sicher ist.
Allerdings würde das ja bedeuten, dass man dann eben diesen Prozess quasi mit
den Betriebssystemherstellern machen müsste und wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe, wäre das mit Google auch irgendwie gar nicht das Problem gewesen,
aber mit Apple funktioniert das nicht,
weil es ja auch noch die Anforderungen gibt, dass das alles Open Source sein soll.
Ja, die Wallet selber muss schon in ihren Applikationskomponenten Open Source sein.
Wir hätten gerne gefordert, und da war Patrick Breyer eine große Hilfe in den
Verhandlungen, dass alles Open Source oder Freisoft sein muss.
Das hat sich leider nicht durchgesetzt, das sind nur die Application Components
und auch da gibt es eine Ausnahme für die Mitgliedstaaten, wenn sie Sicherheitsbedenken
haben, dass sie gewisse Dinge nicht Open Source stellen.
Google ist relativ aktiv in dieser Debatte in Europa.
Bei denen hat man auch das Gefühl, die sehen das als etwas, wo sie auf jeden
Fall auch Android sozusagen mitdenken.
Bei Apple, die fehlen in der Debatte komplett.
Also von denen gibt es sehr wenig Information, wie sie das in ihre bestehende
Apple Wallet einbauen wollen oder ins Betriebssystem.
Man braucht diese Gerätehersteller und Betriebssystemhersteller auf jeden Fall,
weil mittelfristig müssen die privaten Schlüssel hier auf den Sicherheitschips
der Smartphones landen.
Im Moment sind die so als Brückentechnologie auch oft noch in HSMs,
in Hardware Security Models drinnen.
Das will man aber eigentlich nicht, auch aus Gründen der Unbeobachtbarkeit.
Und hier ist auf jeden Fall Kooperation von Nöten, wo auch vor allem Deutschland
darauf drängt, dass man klarer formuliert, dass Apple und Google kooperieren
müssen, was ihre Sicherheitschips betrifft.
Und dein Vorschlag, dass das Ganze ins Betriebssystem eingebaut wird,
damit bist du nicht allein.
Mark Zuckerberg hat sich vor kurzem genau so geäußert.
Der will dieses Altersverifikationsproblem natürlich nicht in seinen Apps haben
und würde sich sehr freuen, wenn das Betriebssystem für ihn dieses Problem löst.
Da hängt ja natürlich auch ein Haftungsrisiko dran.
Ja, also ich meine, ich bin jetzt nicht besonders stolz drauf,
irgendwie mit Mark Zuckerberg einer Meinung zu sein.
Ich komme vielleicht nur zum selben Schluss aus anderen Erwägungen heraus.
Also, dass er das nicht haben will, ich meine, ist ja auch richtig,
weil ich meine, dadurch verteilen wir sozusagen auch das ganze Knowledge auf
tausend Unternehmen und das wird sich nie kontrollieren lassen.
Der einzige Ort, wo es eben wirklich sich kontrollieren lassen wird,
ist eben in diesem Trusted Kern. Und ich meine, wenn man diesen Geräten ohnehin
schon dieses Vertrauen entgegenbringt und das tun wir ja alle.
Wir haben ja unsere Daten da drauf und es ist ja ein riesen Vorteil im Prinzip,
dass man so ein Gerät hat, wo man das eben lokal auch kryptografisch und dann
eben auch biometrisch absichern kann.
Ja und das würde ich ja auch gerne mit meinem Führerschein, meinem Personalausweis etc.
Machen, weil alle Systeme, die wir derzeit haben für online authentifizieren,
sind halt alles solche Krückensysteme.
Wir sehen das ja hier mit dem e-Perso, dann brauchst du irgendwie deine Karte
da nochmal ranhalten und lesen und dann hast du da irgendeine App,
aber wenn die mit einer Webseite kommunizieren sollen, dann müssen die dann
irgendwie so hinten rum und das hatten wir dann hier auch in der Sendung und
dann ist halt dieser Zugang nicht sicher,
weil das einfach nur so eine URL ist, die dann von anderen Programm abgefangen
wird, weil es einfach diesen Kanal nicht gibt.
Obwohl es eigentlich technisch jetzt sozusagen relativ klar wäre so,
ja, nee, dann baut man halt einfach irgendwie Ausweis Authentication als Protokoll damit ein.
Dann ist auch klar, wie das irgendwie mit Webseiten funktioniert.
Nämlich im Vergleich genauso so, wie man das eben mit Kreditkarten heute auch
macht. Ich sage, ich zahle Geld.
Dazu muss ich mich autorisieren. Und in dem Fall würde ich eben sozusagen auch
nochmal die einmal reingeholten Informationen meines Personalausweises entsprechend prüfen oder eben lokal,
sozusagen gegenchecken, wo dann nur die Frage kommt, bist du alt genug?
Und ich so, ja, ich bin alt genug.
Und nur wird das halt einfach bei Apple nicht passieren, wenn man sie zwingt,
Teile ihres Betriebssystems an der Stelle Open Source zu machen.
Was man jetzt wiederum bei Kreditkartenzahlungen nicht macht.
Also, das ist wirklich eine sehr schwierige Diskussion, weil ich verstehe ja
den Wunsch nach Open Source an der Stelle, wo es wirklich um Apps geht,
Aber wenn es eigentlich um Betriebssystemintegration geht, weiß ich nicht,
ob das jetzt irgendwie so zwingend erforderlich ist.
Andererseits will man natürlich als Staat dann auch eine gewisse Überprüfbarkeit
dieses Prozesses haben, aber das ist natürlich auch etwas, was man quasi bilateral
mit diesen Betriebssystemherstellern regeln könnte.
Also es ist wirklich eine vertragte Situation und ich habe so ein bisschen den
Eindruck, wir werden da noch sehr lange warten müssen, bis wir da wirklich die
elegante Lösung haben, weil sich da einfach verschiedene Positionen nochmal ändern müssen.
Ja, ich meine, das habe ich glaube ich in der Sendung auch schon öfter gesagt,
prinzipiell ist für mich das Ausstellen von Ausweisdokumenten klar eine staatliche
Aufgabe, wo ich sehr große Bedenken hätte, das an private Firmen auszulagern.
Das Ausstellen der Ausweise natürlich nicht, also ausstellen ist natürlich nach wie vor der Staat.
Es geht ja hier sozusagen nur um sozusagen eine definierte Überprüfung der Inhalte
und das ist etwas, was man sich auf Protokollebene sicherlich schon realisieren kann,
nur bei der Open Source Debatte wird es dann halt knifflig.
Ja, also im Kern, du redest ja hier auch sehr stark von zertifizierten Komponenten.
Also die European Digital Identity Wallet hat Assurance Level High,
wie das im EU-Sprech heißt.
Also das muss sozusagen den höchsten Anforderungen genügen.
Das ist nicht einfach nur so, wie du denkst, du hast irgendwie einen Ausweis
in die Kamera gehalten, sondern nein, das ist wirklich eine wirklich beglaubigte
staatliche Identität in digitaler Form.
Und natürlich ist hier am Ende ein offenes, protokollbasiertes System die Voraussetzung
dafür, dass das Ganze funktionieren kann. Nur es sind halt so viele Risiken, die du dir aufmachst.
Gerade wenn Google, die davon leben, personalisierte Werbung auszustellen,
denen gerade alles wegbricht, Siehe die Gerichtsverfahren in den USA,
die in der letzten Sendung ja schon angesprochen wurden.
Und da jetzt einfach ihnen auch noch dieses ganz wertvolle Wissen darüber,
ob das eine natürliche Person ist und welche und wo lebt die und wie ist deren
Finanzstatus und Gesundheitsdaten und so weiter.
Da wächst natürlich ein enormes Risiko draus. Und gerade ein Internet,
wo wir wollen, dass es weiter adonyme und pseudonyme Nutzung gibt.
Da müssen wir halt einfach auch wirklich sehr realistisch sein,
was ist der Longtail dieser Technik, in welche Welt führt uns das?
Und da gibt es teilweise gesetzliche Antworten darauf, aber dann teilweise ist
es auch eine Realität, die du schaffst, die halt in anderen Regionen und Jurisdiktionen
auch ganz andere Konsequenzen haben wird.
Ja, guter Punkt. Ja, bleibt eine schwierige Debatte.
Gut, schauen wir mal, was die Prototypen dann zu leisten in der Lage sind.
Letzter Punkt dazu noch, am 12. Dezember ist dann auch in Berlin ein Event, warte, na am 11.
Dezember ist dieser Sprint Pitch Day.
Also wer in Berlin ist und sich diese Sachen anschauen will,
kann da auch hinkommen. Ich glaube, das ist öffentlich.
Ich schaue, dass ich da noch was finde, was ich verlinken kann.
Am 12. Dezember?
Genau, äh, 11. Dezember.
11. Dezember, okay.
Jo, nächstes schwieriges Thema.
Ich wollte das auch noch mal aufgreifen, weil es in der letzten Sendung dankenswerterweise
auch von Linus angesprochen wurde.
Und zwar dieser Fundraiser, den wir bei EPICenterworks hatten.
Es ist immer schwierig, über eigene
Schwächen zu reden, aber als spendenfinanzierte NGO muss man das ja tun.
Und ich wollte einfach noch ein paar Sachen dazu sagen. Das Erste ist,
Aus der Innenperspektive, es fällt nie leicht, über sowas zu reden.
Gerade wenn du so über Schwächen sprichst, wenn du sagst, das Geld geht uns
aus, das ist immer schwierig.
Wir machen das sehr selten. Das letzte Mal, dass wir das tun mussten,
war vor vier Jahren. Und ich spreche es auch jetzt hier nochmal an,
weil ich einfach Danke sagen wollte.
Also wir haben mit diesem Spendenaufruf Mitte Oktober eine riesige Welle an
Unterstützung erfahren.
Es sind über 300 neue Fördermitglieder und unzählige Einzelspenden gekommen.
Ich meine, das lässt sich dann einfach nur demütig und dankbar werden,
wie viel Unterstützung da zusammenkommt für unsere Arbeit.
Wir leben davon, also die Hälfte des Geldes, was wir für unsere neuen Mitarbeiterinnen
brauchen, kommt aus Kleinsspenden und da vor allem die Fördermitglieder sind,
das was den langfristigen Betrieb sichert, weil es Planbarkeit schafft.
Und im Namen des gesamten Teams wollte ich dafür einfach mal Danke sagen.
Wir haben immer noch ein bisschen was offen fürs nächste Jahr.
Dieses Jahr sind wir ausfinanziert.
Für das nächste Jahr ist es einfach so, dass wir noch darum kämpfen,
das Finanzdurch weiter zu stopfen.
Da gibt es auch einen Fortschrittsbalken auf unserer Website.
Es gibt monatliche Cashflow-Berichte und jährliche Transparenzberichte.
Also das kann man alles auf der Website einsehen.
Und zuletzt wollte ich noch irgendwie den Hintergrund liefern,
wieso dieses Finanzloch entstanden ist.
Es ist nämlich so, dass Open Society Foundation, die man ja kennt als diese
philanthropische Stiftung von George Soros,
jüdischer KZ-Überlebender, der dann am Aktienmarkt sehr reich wurde und dafür
bekannt ist, sehr viele progressive NGOs auf der ganzen Welt zu finanzieren.
Der hatte auch, finde ich, die richtige Fury of Change. Der hat in Institutionen
investiert, nicht in Personen.
Der hat nicht wenige sehr große Grants gegeben, sondern viele kleine.
Also ich würde das immer in Erinnerung bleiben, als ich in Georgien war,
die dortige Demokratiebewegung, die ja wirklich Unmenschliches geleistet hat.
Und jetzt gerade auch wieder.
Der einzige Grant, das einzige Fördergeld, was die jemals bekommen haben,
waren 50.000 Euro von OSF.
Und sowas bei uns auch am Anfang. Die geben den kleinen Akteuren halt ihr erstes
Geld und das bringt viel mehr in der Sache meiner Meinung nach,
als jetzt großen NGOs Millionen rüber zu geben.
Leider ist dieses Konzept aber inzwischen gestorben, weil George Soros lebt
zwar noch, ist jetzt über 90 Jahre alt, aber sein Sohn Alex Soros hat übernommen.
Der ist Anfang 30 als Multimilliardär aufgewachsen,
hat einen dementsprechenden Charakter, leider noch keinen Haftbefehl wegen Mafia
gegen sich und zerstört gerade dieses Lebenswerk seines Vaters.
Und für die Netzpolitik bedeutet das, um das auch mal in Zahlen auszudrücken,
dass so mit diesem Jahr zwölf Millionen insgesamt fehlen für alle NGOs in Europa.
Und das ist, wenn man es jetzt mal so umrechnet, schon ein riesiger Batzen auf
die Budgets dieser vielen NGOs, die in Europa an netzpolitischen Themen arbeiten.
Und die fehlen natürlich. Und das macht den Wettbewerb auch härter zwischen
den NGOs. Und das hat auch uns getroffen, weil wir sind in der mittleren Backe.
Es gibt viele, die sind viel größer als wir und dann natürlich auch einige,
die sind kleiner als wir.
Und deswegen war das einfach härter als gedacht, aber es macht sicherlich noch
weiter Sinn, uns zu spenden, wie ich glaube.
Ich meine, ist auch mein Gehalt und erlaubt uns zu arbeiten,
aber es ist auch wichtig, glaube ich, dass diese europäische Arbeit gesehen wird.
Wir haben auch am 38c3 etwas vorbereitet als Vortrag, wo man sehen wird,
wie diese europäische Arbeit insbesondere in Deutschland wirken wird.
Aber das ist natürlich noch geheim.
Das ist noch geheim. Es gibt ein Thema, worüber wir erst im Kongress reden werden
und ich glaube, dass das viele Leute in Deutschland wissen.
Sehr freuen wird. Stichwort schlechtes Internet.
Cue in Cliffhanger Music. Schalten Sie doch das nächste Mal ein.
Ja, sehr schön. Freut mich natürlich, dass das jetzt geklappt hat.
Und es ist natürlich generell ein schwieriges Thema.
Ich weiß noch, als ich hier mit der ganzen Podcasterei angefangen habe.
Haben mich ja auch alle so mit diesem Blick mit ah, du entscheidest dich also
für brotlose Kunst angeschaut.
Und ich hatte eigentlich von Anfang an immer so ein Gefühl mit irgendwie,
ja, es wird schon irgendwie funktionieren.
Und dann hat sich dann in den Jahren danach ja so langsam mit diesen ersten
Crowdfunding-Projekten schon angedeutet, dass ja sozusagen so Community-
basierte Finanzierung von Projekten durchaus eine Realität werden kann.
Dadurch, dass es einfach im Internet ganz andere Möglichkeiten gibt,
seine Arbeit zu dokumentieren oder überhaupt erstmal aktiv zu werden.
Also auch das, was wir jetzt hier mit dem Podcast machen, ist ja nichts,
was vor 30, 40 Jahren auch nur vorstellbar gewesen wäre.
Also es war eigentlich überhaupt erst vor 20 Jahren vorstellbar und vorher war
es bestenfalls erträumbar.
Aber diese ganzen Mechanismen, die heutzutage schon wieder fast selbstverständlich
gelten, sind so neu und so,
in Bewegung auch, wenn man sich eben auch anguckt, das ganze YouTube-Universum,
Patreon da sozusagen als großer.
Spendenverteilapparat, der die in Deutschland, es gibt weitere Projekte,
die ich gar nicht alle aufzählen kann und darüber hinaus natürlich auch eben
sehr viele Wege, wo es eben direkt läuft.
Und das finde ich ja an sich schon mal extrem bemerkenswert,
weil sich dadurch natürlich auch der Support für solche unabhängigen Projekte, wie ihr es auch seid,
sich quasi auch unmittelbar am Bedarf und den Bedürfnissen der Leute ja sozusagen
ein bisschen mitentwickelt.
Weil das ist ja dann auch alles, also Geld, was da gespendet wird,
wird dann eben nicht in andere Dinge gesteckt,
die, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht auch nur den Reichtum von Milliardären mehren
und insofern finde ich das eigentlich auch einen sehr gerechten Umgang damit.
Spenden war natürlich gerade Ende des Jahres natürlich immer ein Thema,
so für diese klassischen karitativen Sachen, aber eben diese kontinuierliche
Unterstützung mit Kleinstbeträgen,
wo ja die einzelnen Beträge vielleicht den Leuten irgendwie gar nicht so wirkmächtig erscheinen,
die aber dann sozusagen in dieser Multiplikation, die dann zwangsläufig im Internet
stattfindet, dann auf einmal dann eben doch eine extreme Kraft entwickelt.
Ich bin immer wieder geprellt davor.
Betrifft auch die Meta-Ebene, die natürlich auch auf dieser Basis läuft, seit jetzt 19 Jahren.
Und ich hatte mit Linus ja letztes Mal auch schon darüber gesprochen,
weil wir generell die Policy haben.
Auch nicht die ganze Zeit sozusagen auf diesem Thema rumzutreten,
weil nervt natürlich auch.
Trotzdem haben mich immer wieder ein paar Fragen erreicht, wollte ich nochmal kurz beantworten.
Also dieses ob man jetzt monatlich, also generell Daueraufträge sind ja irgendwie
das Beste, also weil das macht einfach auch die Planbarkeit extrem groß.
Das sind so Also durch die vielen kleinen regelmäßigen Beträge kriegt man eben
so ein Budget und dann weiß man so, ah okay, dann kann man jetzt also hier auch
mal darin investieren, das machen,
das würde sich jetzt über einen längeren Zeitraum tragen und das gilt ja für euch genauso.
Ihr habt wie viele Mitarbeiter jetzt? Neun?
So ein Team und die wollte ja auch nicht irgendwie monatsweise ein und wieder austreten lassen,
sondern da geht es ja darum auch so eine kontinuierliche Arbeit zu ermöglichen
und manche Arbeit wird vielleicht auch erst irgendwie in ein oder zwei Jahren
dann sichtbar, weil sie eben entsprechende Vorbereitungen und eben regelmäßige Begleitung braucht.
Insbesondere diesen ganzen politischen Prozess da in Europa zu begleiten und
irgendwie immer präsent zu sein und in irgendwelchen Gruppen und Kommissionen
vertreten zu sein, die Reisen zu haben, ansprechbar zu sein,
sichtbar zu werden überhaupt auch erstmal,
dass man überhaupt erstmal so ein Thema wird und dann kann man dann eben die
Gelegenheit ergreifen,
wenn es dann wieder hart auf hart kommt und irgendeine Gesetzesinitiative an
den Start gebracht wird, wo sich alle nur am Kopf hauen und sagen so, oh mein Gott,
ihr habt sie ja wohl nicht mehr alle, da müssen wir jetzt mal dringend was gegen
unternehmen. Dann muss man halt da sein.
Und das ist nicht der Zeitpunkt, wo man dann startet und wo man irgendwie nach
Geld fragt, sondern es geht eben aus so einer kontinuierlichen Arbeit heraus.
Entsteht eigentlich erst diese Kraft.
Und so ein bisschen ist es ja auch mit diesem Podcast, der irgendwie immer da
ist und vielleicht mal seine Längen hat Und aber dann auch immer wieder dazu
in die Debatte treten kann, wenn es darum geht,
irgendwelche Dinge zu verstehen, zu unterstützen oder sonst wie bekannt zu machen.
Insofern, Daueraufträge sind immer the best.
Manche fragen, ob es irgendwie monatlich oder jährlich ist. Mir ist das ehrlich gesagt ziemlich Wumpe.
Monatliche Beiträge lassen sich besser einschätzen. Jährliche Beiträge erzeugen
weniger Sekundärkosten, weil wir ja immer alle noch mitverdienen bei den ganzen
Transaktionen heutzutage.
Ich habe dann übrigens auch die
letzten Tage ein bisschen meine Webseite verbessert für die Einmalspender.
Kann man jetzt auch mit Google Pay bezahlen. Das ist ganz neu.
Ganz, ganz tolles Feature. Habt ihr bestimmt noch nie ausprobiert.
Müsst ihr unbedingt mal ausprobieren. Könnt ihr machen, auf der Meta-Ebene.
Jetzt aber auch Ruhe im Karton mit Geld.
Ja, ja, ja. Du hast ja jetzt gerade von Kleinstbeträgen geredet und ich finde
da ist auch nochmal technisch anzumerken, wie toll SEPA ist.
Also weil du hast bei vielen Zahlungsmethoden dann gewisse Gebühren,
die anfallen, egal ob du jetzt irgendwie PayPal oder Stripe verwendest und direkte
Überweisung oder ein SEPA Einziehungsauftrag ist halt auch frictionless money.
Und das erlaubt dann halt eben auch, dass sogar wenn du wirklich nur einen Euro
gibst, kommt auch ein Euro an.
Natürlich gibt es irgendwo hinten rum Kontoführungsgebühren,
aber die werden eher aggregiert. Das ist halt die Frage, was du für einen Deal mit deiner Bank hast.
Als gemeinnütziger Verein haben wir da überhaupt nichts. Das heißt,
du kannst so ähnlich wie diese Idee von Flatter früher war,
halt einfach auch dein Geld so aufteilen, dass es in der Summe immer noch in
dem Rahmen ist, der für dich vertretbar ist und trotzdem eine relativ gute Steuerungsfunktion machen.
Und ich glaube, das ist ein Asset, was vielen Leuten nicht bewusst ist,
dass es da halt eben gar nicht darum geht, ob man es sich leisten kann,
sondern die Summe, die dann bei den Leuten ankommt, ist das,
was den von dir erwähnten Effekt möglich macht.
Also du hast doch absolut recht, oft ist es halt dieses.
Wirklich dann auf die relevanten Themen gehen nicht da, wo jetzt gerade die Buzzwords sind.
Die Buzzwords sind gerade bei KI und alle machen jetzt gerade KI und das ist
so, alle laufen diesem einen Ding hinterher und dann werden aber so,
AI, das ist ein super Beispiel, dreieinhalb Jahre, keine Sau interessiert sich,
jetzt auf einmal wird es relevant,
würden jetzt NGOs anfangen zu arbeiten damit, dein Impact ist einfach so gering,
weil das Gesetz ist geschrieben, ist verabschiedet.
Das ist einfach wichtig dafür, das ist so ein bisschen auch,
was man als Supporter ausdrückt und man kriegt dann eben auch ein T-Shirt dafür.
Also bei Lockruppen und Netzpolitik, ihr habt ja den cooleren Swag,
wir haben nur dieses eine coole When Politicians Fail Epicenter Works T-Shirt
und ich glaube, das ist alles, was wir liefern können.
Und die letzte Sache, die ich sagen wollte, ich hoffe, deine Bahncard 100,
mit der das alles angefangen hat bei dir, hast du gerahmt irgendwo noch an der
Wand hängen. Weil an die erinnere ich mich noch gut.
Damals hast du selber noch nicht dran geglaubt, dass das so gut funktionieren wird.
Und ich finde, diese Bahncard 100 hätte auf jeden Fall einen Rahmen verliehen.
Das stimmt. Ich glaube, das habe ich verpasst, die 1-2-Rahmen.
Aber es war tatsächlich, war das so ein bisschen der Ausschlaggebung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich nicht dran glaube, ich habe schon irgendwie es für möglich gehalten.
Aber der Effekt war ja damals noch viel krasser,
weil es ja sozusagen, weil mir so viel Geld gespendet wurde,
dass ich mir nicht nur diese Bahnkarte 100 kaufen konnte, sondern ich konnte
im Prinzip auch die komplette Initialausstattung des Studios hier damit bezahlen,
was sonst, was überhaupt noch gar nicht in meinem Kopf war.
Von daher war das einfach der ultimative Kick-Off damals,
aber es ist eben vor allem diese regelmäßige Begleitung, die es wirklich ausmacht,
weil es uns einfach in diese beneidenswerte Privileg gibt,
so ein bisschen auch immer Zeit zu haben,
in die Zeit zu schauen.
Dieses permanente Beobachten der Welt und Beobachten der News und im Gespräch zu bleiben.
Das ist ja etwas für vielen Leuten, sodass diese tägliche Berufswelt eigentlich
weitgehend genommen wird.
Man ist so eingenommen mit Daily Drop und mit den ganzen Themen,
die man dann privat vielleicht noch drum herum hat,
dass es eben ein extremer Wert ist,
einfach da die Ruhe zu haben und zu sagen, ich schaue mir einfach diese Entwicklung
an und dann poppt wieder irgendwas auf auf Social Media und das Hashtag du jour
und der nächste Hype bricht sich Bahn.
Und das dann aber auch wirklich intensiv begleiten zu können,
sich seine Gedanken darüber zu machen und um dann auch wirklich eine informierte
Entscheidung darüber zu treffen, wie reden wir darüber,
wie gehen wir damit um, was hat das für einen Impact.
Ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut, wie diese ganze Debatte umgekehrt.
Bitcoin und Cryptocurrency, das fing so an mit, ah ja, das ist sowieso technisch,
Nerds probieren da irgendwas aus und dann hatte das natürlich irgendwie so seinen
Appeal, aber dann so nach ein paar Jahren wurde schnell klar.
Oh oh, das ist nicht nur mehr so eine technische Nerdgeschichte,
sondern hier bricht sich so ein politischer Weg auf einmal Bahn,
der extrem von so libertären,
neoliberalen Gedanken geprägt ist und jetzt sehen wir halt mit der Wahl in den USA,
wie auf einmal dieses ganze Kryptogeld Politik macht und sogar den Vizepräsidenten
stellt und welche Rolle Elon Musk und seinen Kryptowahn da noch in den nächsten Jahren auslösen wird,
das lässt sich glaube ich derzeit noch gar nicht mal so richtig abschätzen.
Aber dafür dann auch frühzeitig so ein Gefühl zu entwickeln mit,
kommt da was Cooles oder ist das einfach schon wieder die nächste Kuh,
die wir irgendwie vom Eis schieben müssen.
Da bin ich sehr dankbar dafür, diesen Freiraum zu haben und das ist das,
was ihr alle ermöglicht.
Jetzt haben wir doch noch mit Trump geendet aber.
Das Thema wird auch nochmal aufkommen glaube ich,
Thomas vielen Dank und ich denke wir werden uns auch nächste Woche wieder treffen
während Linus noch eine kleine Auszeit nimmt ja und dann,
entlassen wir euch erstmal in die Woche und sagen tschüss und bis bald bis.
Bald, ciao ciao.